I just want to get a cup of coffee yes
that's why we're here this is the best
place to get one in Naples now we come
over here and we pay first there it's
obsessed in Italy with paying first what
if I'm not happy with losing one's gonna
sing you know I have you a cappuccino
and do a special no Molly you know what
I love about Naples people stand and get
their coffee they don't sit in a corner
and write a screenplay for four hours -
no enemy is called expresso it's an
express activity you get in and you get
out you go about your day it's called
expresso it's an express activity
actually espresso means press down and
then no way the first is community board
that's for Center and then you should
take filming so Jay coming yes like I
want a cocktail
you missed the entire preparation of the
coffee you were talking to that one okay
this is a Neapolitan cappuccino 150
milliliters it's only 25 milliliters of
coffee made from 7 grams of beans and
then about 4 ounces of milk look at this
man's elegance watches movements it's a
ballet at the Machine no movement is
wasted everything is perfect look at him
though it's a dance it's a dancing man
and machine no it's not
[Applause]
just pick the center one shot just had a
real experience you should enjoy that
guys one shot seven grams of coffee shut
up I don't know how many grams are in
here shut up whoa that was good
not gonna have another one no I'm
satisfied I know when to stop and I do
not
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
four grams of coffee seven grams of
water
mmm six ounces traditional traditional
traditional
tell them I want a pumpkin spice latte
new girl a moonlit cafe latte kwang-soo
compiled a pocket on the juga yeah yeah
I don't know yoga no dukka dukka yeah no
nope
tell them I had too much coffee purple
carpet I'm crazy when I have the coffee
oh you know it's craziness too much
coffee too much coffee
wave too much coffee ladies this is so
nice of you to give me all these gifts
give me you either give me the watch
nice to the American you get it give me
that let's give me that watch Hey
Naples I just found this guy he's
incredible sir I have been born in
Naples this is what I'd be doing right
now
a sexual junkie no Marat I've never seen
a statue with such an impressive crotch
bulge look at that that's totally
unnecessary someone accused him of us
stuffing his pants right and he's like
me stuff with my dad I just saw this
this is the most frightening ice-cream
display I've ever seen in that but I
don't know how this why would anyone
want to buy ice cream from this guy he
looks he's got the blood of his latest
victim it's mop right here Joe Joe
Jordan why not wish to be viewed by us
maybe they're shy they don't need to be
on television to self validate seniority
wanna stand up wanna say wanna say wanna
stand it securely can we come up see it
okay okay now how do we get in this will
be the last footage ever seen of us
alive
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
while we were in Naples I was invited to
appear on Italy's most famous soap opera
une postal I'll soldered in the Liberty
City multiple Minos have a stable Tito
obviously they had seen my work in soap
operas all over the world gusto
now I was about to continue my tradition
of playing a romantic lead this time
with on post Joe's beautiful Valentina
Pucci
oh my god please my friend will help
interpret this is my friend Jordan she's
doing nude women is there any place for
him in this scene maybe even just a
quick he walks by hey dude yeah wow yeah
yeah and before I knew it it was time
for my big scene
[Music]
not maintained at school teacher the bus
Connecticut's bike on LeBron plus Jordan
made his so property view
[Applause]
you